okay here we are on CNN
however that happened we're glad to be
here we have author of The New York
Times newsletter John McWhorter and we
have Emmy York winning producer and
journalist Josh Karen go okay here are
the questions I hold in my hand let me
do a Karnak tonight
uh nobody under 75.
well they see it on YouTube no you're
right they don't even do that all right
with a with a former CDC director
testifying before Congress that gain of
function Labs probably caused the
pandemic uh should be rethinking our
approach to scientific research well I
don't know about scientific research but
gain a function I don't know if people
know what gain of function is but that
is how possibly this escaped and it's
very very scary to me because a gain of
function means we're taking the virus
manipulating in a lab to make it worse
so we could study that if if the worst
happens which does happen when it
escapes
I would say this about that I'll just
jump in you can argue if we think
nuclear power
we can't have it some people think that
because it's great except for that one
in a thousand chance that it goes bad it
goes so bad isn't this the same thing
gain and function isn't it very similar
to nuclear yeah it feels pretty
self-evident that we ought to have the
highest possible restrictions for this
kind of research because the you know I
come from a people who always worry
about the worst possible outcome this is
the worst possible outcome put that
first
yeah I mean if it happens that the virus
evolves way worse naturally we'll deal
with it then but to bring it about seems
crazy this uh this should have been
really rethought yes it's exactly like
the nuclear issue I don't see how the
issues are different all right what
impact if any can we expect the collapse
of Silicon Valley Bank oh yes to have on
our financial system if you didn't see I
saw this has just happened in a Silicon
Valley Bank one of the biggest banks in
Silicon Valley obviously attack
obviously they're check right that's
what they finance I think the biggest
bank failure since the 2008 crash I
guess we should have seen it coming
because there's been a lot of layoffs
and bit Bitcoin is this is this is that
what this bank is Bitcoin
so the Silicon Valley Banks is 40 year
old bank from the valley it was designed
and funded originally to to make sure
that startups which have a tough time
getting money could get some money if
this were called the Lehigh Valley Bank
we would not really be paying that much
attention to it it's the Silicon Valley
Bank part that's sexy but the truth is
it's a small bank so it's got about 150
billion in capital JPMorgan has three
trillion the the only reason to be
concerned about it is the knock-on
effects of confidence but it's a small
back that got caught short so you know
the story in the world are we bailing
out Bitcoin losers no it's not this is
not about this is about a shortfall
where they misaligned their bond
spending with the amount coming in they
lost depositor confidence that happened
overnight
possible this gets contained is it
absolutely Central to the startup
industry or is it just a bank that some
startups it used to be 40 years ago it
is no longer right now yeah speaking of
tech Elon Musk just announced that he
plans to build his own Utopia in Austin
Texas
[Laughter]
with the affordable affordable housing
for his employees I mean he is a
Visionary he does I mean we didn't see
electric cars or relatable Rockets or
you know living on Mars I mean this guy
thinks big uh what are your what are
your thoughts by the way if I was going
to build Utopia or respect to Austin I
wouldn't put it there
and I like Austin I like Austin a lot
sure I keep it weird every time I go he
is intuitiveness and I'm not sure that
he's thought hard enough about how a
Utopia would actually work beyond the
kind of Disney World beautiful picture
that it would be in the beginning I
don't trust him to do this I think I'd
rather see a bunch of people put their
heads together but no such thing as
utopia how about that don't don't ever
use the word Utopia or think you can
create a utopian or that what a Fool's
errand that everybody would be talk
about an over-promising con man I'm
gonna build it's also like Utopia is is
a personal concept and my personal
concept isn't the same as elon's I'm
pretty sure and so like my first thought
yeah my first thought was like well I
definitely will not be living there
[Laughter]
wow
I could think of worse places to live
and worst people to live under uh with
college enrollment down nationwide yes I
read that today College enrollment kids
are finally getting the hint skip
College it's a bunch of well
I'm editorializing on oh sorry
all right twice in five weeks I messed
up uh two out of five I'm gonna get
better are young people catching on to
the yes to the fact that yes yes card
I agree with you card our young people
catching on to the fact that college may
not be worth the investment they better
there is too much guys
oh Lord there's too much right too much
goddamn college right I teach that's
where the university
but no there shouldn't be this idea that
to be a normal American is to spend four
years living in a dormitory pretending
to like Shakespeare
[Applause]
that idea that everybody's supposed to
go to college everybody is supposed to
get a good solid high school education
that's another rant but then you're
supposed to go out and play a trade
unless you want to do the rather
rarified thing of go to college that's
one way that the old days were better
than now it's Mission creep that
everybody goes to college and it's not
true that if you don't go to college you
are going to be selling pencils on the
street there are many perfectly
legitimate careers we just need to learn
how to talk about it more right the
other thing that could not agree more
thank you
there's a
another phenomenon that I think is
fascinating which is kids are learning
how to do stuff professionally from
YouTube that's a good point and so if
you are a coder more often than not
you're watching a 90 minute video on how
to use CSS wow and it's moving at your
own pace frequently much faster than the
education system can possibly get you
there one example from this weekend the
Daniels the guys who directed everything
everywhere alt wants they went to film
school and they are the ones who say
don't ever go to film School watch
YouTube
so well that's for sure that that's for
sure true about the art about the Arts
you don't need School for the Arts in
fact they probably make it work right I
mean either you have it you don't I mean
it's just not something you can learn in
school PhD in a guy with an MMA yeah of
course yeah don't be like us okay so you
can learn that on YouTube but what about
you mentioned Shakespeare now was that
will you let me read into that were you
saying Shakespeare is past is prime I
was being hyperbolic but do you still
like Shakespeare Shakespeare is a swell
guy but you should learn you should
learn about him in high school all of
that should be packed in much more
should be packed into the high school
education maybe even have a 13th grade
then if you're going to go into Finance
go work in a bank you can work in a bank
when you're 19. that's the way I I would
like it to be Shakespeare is great but
the four years where your mind is being
expanded expand your mind when you're a
teenager then go get a job there's
nothing abnormal
they're expanding their minds when
they're ready
that's the problem okay uh Walmart just
announced that they're closing their
last two stores in Portland oh
in part due to rampant theft does this
reflect a lacks attitude toward crime in
Liberal cities uh well portly at
Portland is one of those cities I could
see where Walmart would have some
problems it would be like it's just not
worth it but I mean gosh that says
something not good about this country
that stores are saying gosh we're just
going to give up rather than we can't
even make a go of it because the
security situation is so poor I mean
that I I don't want to live in that
country where we can't keep a Walmart
open in a major city
I mean Portland has a problem like
Portland is devastated it is chaos town
I'm going there soon how bad it's bad
you should you should be careful really
even at the comedy show
I would say especially at the comedy
show I mean
[Applause]
what if I need shaving cream at the last
minute where am I going to go airport
man airport Walmart and also if you go
into a store in Portland the shaving
cream in the deodorant is behind one of
those things and you have to press a
button to get someone to open it for you
for shaving cream New York is full of
that right now yeah New York has I'm
beginning to order that stuff on Amazon
because I get tired of waiting for that
person as if Amazon didn't need any more
help I feel guilty right about it yeah
right no it's you know actually large
stores moving away especially from
Center cities that's 50 years old
because of crime it's in old story and
it's hard to fix crime in a real way
without Draconian measures that often
create more harm than help but no that's
a that's that's an old story I'm not I'm
not surprised what surprises me is that
there were Walmarts sitting in what
would be considered Central Portland
because it certainly wouldn't work in
Philadelphia Cincinnati or from what I
hear even Denver well I remember missed
a stand-up show I always loved Portland
and I'm going there I'm not sure when it
is but look it up on my website all
right thank you CNN thank you guys that
was a lot of fun thank you
thank you